what's going on i mean people are
getting beat up uh tyson on airplanes
johnny
i mean yeah for tyson i'm assuming
everybody here saw tyson oh yeah with
the video did you see the video of the
guy recording the guy and he's like
bothering him and the other guy's
laughing and it's like bro there's only
so many times you could poke a bear to
the bears and like all right but i'm
gonna be here here's when you what was
your first reaction when you watched
when you started hitting him i was just
like i don't know how he got because you
know mike has these little angles he was
rocking that dude's face bro oh my god
what do you what did you think about
like what did you think about the guy
not tyson what did you think about the
guy trolling him like how did you
process him hmm i didn't get to hear
what he was saying like that's
everything right dude do we know what he
wants to say what he did can you pull up
the video because i think we can see the
video it's not like you'd say
yeah and so he was saying something
about because the guy recording was like
he's bothering uh michael i'm not sure
there's a better video there's a video
that shows a side video
because the guy's like the guy's like
laughing he's like hey he's bothering
mike tyson about shrooms and it's funny
and it's laughing and then dude it took
mike a while bro he he yeah that was
talking for a minute and he just did you
hear what he said pat
yeah the guy's like he's he's in mike
because they're look this is this is not
fair to show that video
they're not showing this clown
trying to clown tyson
that's what they're not showing all
they're showing is tyson beating up the
guy tyson's in his uh seat he's not
doing anything this guy's over him
is this the one yeah play this one make
this one bigger oh yeah that's like how
much of that [ __ ] are you going to take
oh yeah
go back go back a little bit yeah i
watch this
oh this is great
exactly as long as you're allowed to do
that
what are you thinking dude
man he over here with tyson how many
seconds can you do that tomorrow
trying to give us some shrooms trying to
give us some shrooms
well look he's trying to have his wallet
he got his money
he should have never gave you his money
peasants peasants
and then all of a sudden oh and then
guess what
show the next clip
[Music]
how much money is going to make
how much money is he going to make turn
around look at that
there you go oh dude how much money he's
going to make pat
think about that
think about how much money this this
i mean dude i mean i don't know he that
guy you know
the thing that stands out to me is i'm
leaning over his
over tyson's seat
you know physically so
i don't think he got rocked yeah i mean
he got i think he got what he deserved
because of the
infiltration of his physical space i
think people punching each other for
saying something's bad but that guy was
physically annoying oh that may be it
makes me happy though finally it's like
people are just but listen if there's a
famous quote on on internet the quote is
yes everybody acts tough yeah until
somebody punches you in the face
exactly that's mike's quote yep so you
know what i like what dana white posted
did you see that's what they know i
posted about it which is sick dana white
says this hey idiots look at this he
says hey dummies for your future for
future references just move c doesn't
move that's so badass let me tell you
something i love this i'll tell you why
number one you know who feels bad for
this guy they got beat up
absolutely [ __ ] nobody nobody okay no
we've met mike tyson you've you did an
hour-long interview with mike tyson in a
freaking boxing ring
in uh where were we in vegas mgm we're
in vegas and [ __ ] mgm yeah
okay you couldn't have asked for a more
chilled out nicer guy remember when he
wreaked the weed he was of course he was
smoking weed before after during
whatever yeah i we went i said hey mike
let's take a picture let's put your
hands up you know he goes he goes man
i'm trying to fight you man put your
hands down let's shake it like as sweet
as they come yeah do you know what you
end up you're not telling the whole
story though you're not telling the
whole story what's the whole story he
was so high i just said that within five
no no it was so
bad that within five minutes i was
asking for cheeto
i wanted to eat i'm like i can't do this
anymore
but the interview was fantastic he he
was great yeah and if you didn't know
who mike tyson was you said this guy is
a freaking pacifist yeah like you don't
other than the roy jones thing remember
the one line when he fought joy jones he
says like everyone feels bad about roy
jones he's like i haven't fought yeah in
like 10 years rory jones just retired
two years ago and the guys what's the
one jim gray and he's like you're
freaking mike tyson everyone expects you
to force
yeah and look this guy got what he paid
for but you're talking [ __ ] to mike
tyson in an enclosed
capsule in the sky enjoy your [ __ ]
but i guarantee you he's going to make
he's going to make a lot of money that
guy i don't know about that
because all right ready for this yeah i
feel you about the space just like any
man like no i would have punched him one
hundred percent i don't give a [ __ ] who
the person is but mike is sitting down
the guy yeah is talking behind him but
mike got up turned around and physically
assaulted a guy on an airplane i and i'm
with you guys he's going to sue and he's
going to make money i guarantee you oh
you mean that way you mean through a
loss 100
oh yeah maybe the air i don't know i
mean he probably can't through the
airline but
yeah you could talk all this [ __ ] that
you want mike tyson who has money beat
the [ __ ] out of the guy trust me he's
going to get a lawsuit he's going to use
the billy madison defense 100 that's
assault brother
exactly exactly and don't be wrong i
love i've i've i've had many experiences
i just did the laugh factory tone like
about two three weeks ago and i i adore
mike tyson bro he i look and it's
chocolate sundaes and he's sitting right
there and i was just like oh i was just
about to do that joke like not even a
joke but i was like in l.a like a week
before mike tyson was at a comedy show
and some guy pulled out a gun on the
house and and the guy's like hey look in
front of mike and mike just went come
here and the guy was like i love your
mic and hug mike with the gun wow i love
you guys you guys saw that no it was a
it was a [ __ ] it was crazy mike tyson is
so amazing and so mike the guy was like
i just love you i hugged him he hugged
mike and then he left with a gun the
thing with mike tyson is most many
athletes many fighters especially
don't have a second act no right like
you guys can do comedy and like to your
freaking don rickles into you're 90
freaking years old you can do comedy
fighters don't really have a second act
mike tyson has reinvented himself 100 as
this like lovable huggable character
actor everything yeah everything i mean
the hangovers a lot of it yeah big time
speaking doing interviews with
everything doing the hot boxing what was
the thing that uh you said that he did
recently hot boxing with uh francis
nagano yeah we talked about it he's
really he's turned into like he went
from the baddest [ __ ] on the
planet yeah to like the most lovable
nicest guy and he's cuz he's always high
exactly and we just got to remember yeah
you know he's still he's a [ __ ] beast
yep oh this is it this is you guys saw
this yeah and then mike he literally
hugged look at mike mike's like come
here do a gun was drawn and mike tyson
didn't even stand up look he's like come
here man give me a hug you armed son of
a [ __ ]
it's crazy
this is the same room that i saw another
video
yeah
this is not the this is in hollywood bro
next to roscoe's and chicken and waffles
you know you know what i'm talking about
they need to stop
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you